exits will Nick Cannon be invited and
for bride-to-be julianne hough would we
see Ryan Seacrest Jin perros asked
former the hills and Laguna Beach star
turned lifestyle guru Lauren Conrad who
recently released her ninth book called
celebrate one chip that you given the
book is kind of like the unwritten rule
of weddings is that you're not allowed
to invite your ex-boyfriend all rules
are made to be broken if you do you like
whatever you guys want whatever's gonna
represent you as a couple um and
whatever makes you happy ok so how does
a bride avoid breaking the bank the
moment you say wedding like the price
triples so it's important to really do
your research there and like meet with
several different people compare quotes
because you can get reasonable prices
you just kind of to do a little hunting
Lauren's kind a pro in party planning
since her 2014 walked down the aisle to
William Tell we caught up with the 25
million dollar mini mogul at Sirius XM's
leading lady Series in New York where
she dropped one final wedding tip plan
beforehand using Pinterest I love that
you were really real about what a lot of
girls do that you had a wedding
Pinterest board and then the second you
got engaged you unlocked it you're like
oh wow I've actually been planning this
entire thing I mean I before you even
know me I did it at the table like he
had just proposed and I was like I have
some thoughts